good morning guys
this is a video about what i've learned
living in kiev ukraine
for what is almost the past four
years and so what do i got
11 points here start with number one
and that is planning so when i first
came here
a friend of mine she had a she has an
english language school and she asked me
to
help out with a few conversation classes
so i went in and my topic was
where do you see yourself in five years
look how beautiful this is
love these murals where do you see
yourself in five years
and i got a bunch of blank uh
distant looks like uh all right foreign
guy
uh what's what's with the the the
misunderstanding or the lack of
knowledge about our
cultural context and so i learned
very quickly that in a place where
there's lot been a lot of instability
geopolitical instability that people
don't really plan out
five years versus the us where people
out five years ten years maybe all the
way till retirement
uh and now i get it now i get it because
of code
it all makes sense to all of us it's
very hard to plan out
when you don't know or have an
understanding
of what the future brings so
planning number one number two
less aggressive culture now we see
in the movies the slavic guy is always
the bad guy
always the uh the gangster the mafiosa
guy
uh yeah they exist that's for sure but
uh
really on the streets it's chill
like i haven't had any problems even in
the so-called rough neighborhoods here
that i've been to uh yeah things happen
there is crime and danger here
but as i can an average citizen
it's uh it feels quite safe
the biggest dangers here are if you're
in journalism
if you're high level in business or
politics
those are dangerous places to be for
some
but for the average person it's uh quite
chill
the biggest dangers here actually are
well i'm not seeing it here but
the buildings some of the buildings
are are crumbling and so you see these
bricks
in the streets and that's because they
fell from above
and also the old soviet elevators
these things are quite sketchy you know
they've never been maintained
and it's only a matter of time before
uh it's gonna break down on someone so
those are the biggest dangers here
not what we typically think i would say
learned about
america and
you don't really understand what your
country is until you're out of it for a
long time so it's like this it's like
a football game and on the field you're
in the game
that's when you're in your country and
when you're out of your country
you're in the stands looking at the game
totally different perspective and so by
living over here i've been
able to be a spectator
of the usa which is very interesting
that's a whole nother video i'll make
but it's like if you always wear running
shoes
you don't know what dress shoes feel
like
that's a far-reaching metaphor but i
think you know what i mean like you
don't know until you've
felt something else then you know what
the other is like
every country has problems
just different problems and so
one of ukraine's biggest problems there
are many problems here but one of the
biggest ones
is you know having russia as a neighbor
it's a big uh powerful country
uh on its border that's a problem
and if you look at the us right now what
is it what is it one of its biggest
problems
let's say this identity politics this
this woke culture
uh friction tension
uh both problems completely different
problems
people here get by with less the average
person so
it's a less wealthy country people can't
finance basic things like most people
are not financing
their mattress or normal things in life
even
cars i think a lot of people pay cash in
apartments a lot of people pay cash
which i still don't understand how they
save that money
so in america you see more things
and it's sort of an image that might not
reflect
someone's true wealth and here
you sort of you see how it is now there
is
look at this one love that mural
don't get me wrong there is a very
material culture here
i've seen more of the uh mercedes
maubeck i believe it's called the
maubeck it's like
200 000 i think a lot of these guys are
paying cash
so there is the the very puffy lips
exotic car crowd it is very material in
that sense
best and worst of people so i've had
three landlords in this country
the first one uh absolute nightmare
very aggressive uh only
only shouted didn't have any other tone
of language
um really difficult situation now the
third landlord our last landlord
fantastic really cool really sweet uh
the woman even uh painted a picture for
us
my wife and i like just as a present
no no uh no birthday no
special reason just to paint us a
painting
so you get the far far
extremes and i see that also with most
people i feel like it's a very
authentic cool culture in most respects
most people and then you get this you
know mafiosa crowd which is very
uh like unsavory i would say it looks
like a lot of these guys eat
nails for breakfast but you're not
really interacting with
with that environment i realized how
important environment is in life
and what do i mean by that i mean the
air you breathe
oh that's not one of the super nice ones
but that's just an example
the air you breathe and so the buses
here
don't have catalytic converters they
spew all these all this exhaust out into
the air
a lot of vehicles don't have catalytic
converters and there are no real
emission standards
didn't really notice it year one by year
three it really
has started started to get to me and it
gives me headaches
and it's unfortunate because the
authorities
the the government here the mayor
doesn't seem
to think it's an issue and there i
haven't seen any
measures to change the problem and it's
interesting
this is an athletic guy a boxer somebody
spends a lot of time in germany
which does have these standards
political correctness
uh doesn't really exist which is
refreshing
i mean no one likes blatant rudeness but
it's sort of nice to
you know you know where you stand
nobody's really like
padding their language uh trying to make
you feel good
if they do they mean it they don't they
don't
and uh there's just less sensitivity
overall with language
instability so ukraine has felt a lot of
instability in the 20th century
and a lot of the 21st century so banking
crisis
revolutions these things have
well are in the um subconscious of the
people
and it's more baked into the dna that
hey your money
half of it can be gone the next morning
hey there can be an invading uh force
on your country and so with the coveted
times we're in
it just seems like there's not much
tension with that
from my observation uh people don't
seem to be so worried is because when
you
compare to other things that have
happened here it's really quite a small
issue geography makes uh
a country what it is to some respect so
ukraine's geography is cursed it's
the high european plane between russia
and europe and that's never been a
stable place to be it's been the place
for invading armies
if i'm going to compare to the us the us
us's geography is very
calm two big oceans allied beloved
above and below so
it can be looked at as a a difficulty
for sure but it also has shaped
the place and the people into what they
are today
and there's a there's a good side in
that because i do
find the culture and most of the people
that i've
interacted with to be freaking cool like
it's
it's a cool culture now they're
everywhere and
i'm not going to sugarcoat it ukraine's
got plenty of problems
and plenty of bad actors but in general
how i've been received here how people
have acted towards me
uh it's been really nice i gotta say for
the most part
freedom
[Music]
there's a lot of freedom here that's an
ambiguous word
it depends your your life your
socioeconomic standing
it depends on a lot of things uh
freedoms really could be you know
reflected only in your minds not the
external circumstances but if i'm to say
living in the country as an outsider
or even for a lot of people here it's
very free
people park on the sidewalks there are
no petty rules nobody's going to
complain if you ride your bike
wherever uh you know
there's a problem too with not having
rules for example the emissions controls
that i was talking about like that is a
pain in the ass but as far as you want
freedom you want freedom to voice your
opinion you want freedom to do what you
want as long as you're not
interfering with others it's uh you want
to you want
freedom to say what you want and not
fear getting cancelled or outcasted
ukraine is probably one of the better
places to be
you can see in the center here they're
uh
doing some bike lanes new sidewalks
uh so some
surface level changes that make the city
look better but they really again
gotta work on the whole air pollution
thing uh you don't see too many vehicles
it's a saturday today
uh but when the city gets pumping the
air goes to hell
if you've never lived abroad and have
the chance to do so no matter where
you're from if you have a chance to live
in another country
strongly recommend it you'll learn a lot
about your own country
you'll learn a lot about the country
you're in you'll learn a lot about
yourself
uh i've grown a lot here in this country
has given me a lot it's a teacher let's
say
it's a teacher it's not always going to
be easy um
but you get a lot out of it for sure and
if you are that foreigner
that moves to another country your guest
your guest in someone's home don't go in
with muddy boots
go unrespectful bring a present meaning
give something to to the place you know
hire some employees
uh teach a language help in some way
shape or form
um create content that
you know shows the other side you know
ukraine's content in the world is is
99 negative and i understand the
problems here i'm not going into them
right now
but i feel it's a bit unjust it deserves
some of
uh the positives too so guys
thanks for coming along if you want to
see more about ukraine i have a playlist
i'll have it down below i'll link down
below a ton of ukrainian videos
and that's it thanks for coming along
until next one